voy a tomar un punto aquí en la pantalla
que voy a pintar en amarillo y le voy a
llamar el punto a lo que me interesa es
a encontrar todos los puntos que estén
en la pantalla que estén a dos
centímetros de a por ejemplo este punto
por aquí que le voy a llamar be parece
estar a dos centímetros vamos a pensar
que en realidad son dos centímetros
saleh es decir ave la longitud ave es
igual a dos centímetros
recuerda que si no tiene barrita es la
longitud si le pusiera ave así con
barrita me referiría al segmento bueno
pero ven no es el único punto que está a
dos centímetros de a hay otro punto más
o menos por acá más o menos por acá que
también está a dos centímetros déjame
llamarle c es decir tal que hace también
es igual a dos centímetros dos
centímetros va déjame tomar tomar la
herramienta recta para dibujar el
segmento y bueno podríamos seguir
encontrando varios puntos que están a
distancia dos centímetros de a y si
consideramos todos ellos va a aparecer
una figura que seguramente con
déjame tomar déjame tomar la herramienta
para dibujarla y nos quedaría más o
menos algo así nos quedaría algo de este
estilo un círculo seguramente ya conoces
los círculos déjame escribirle por acá
círculo
por lo menos seguramente ya conoces los
círculos pero es muy importante esto que
un círculo está formado por aquellos
puntos que están a una distancia fija de
un punto dado entonces si variaremos la
distancia por ejemplo si fuera tres
centímetros
podríamos tener otro círculo verdad
tendríamos un círculo un poco más grande
digamos algo de este estilo pero ahorita
no me interesa dibujar círculos de
muchos tamaños sino hablar acerca de las
partes de un círculo y algunas
definiciones relacionadas porque con eso
vamos a poder después hacer un poco más
de matemáticas ahorita explico un poco
más déjame empezar definiendo algunas
cosas este punto que está justo en medio
del círculo es súper importante y le
vamos a llamar el centro del círculo eso
es bastante razonable porque coincide
con con la idea que tenemos en la vida
real de que es el centro de una cosa va
está justo en medio entonces este punto
se le conoce como centro ya la distancia
que va del centro a la orilla del
círculo se le conoce como radio
también hace a un segmento que vaya del
centro a la orilla del círculo por
ejemplo aquí ave ave es un radio es
radio radio
sale entonces estoy siendo muy cuidadoso
ave
ave es el segmento verdad si le ponemos
así barrita entonces un segmento es es
un segmento es un radio del círculo si
empieza en el centro y va hacia la
orilla estoy siendo muy concreto y muy
específico porque ahorita en geometría
es de las primeras ocasiones en las
cuales nos vamos a meter con matemáticas
un poco más formales pero que también
son más interesantes
después de definir algunas cosas vamos a
poder demostrar algunas proposiciones y
con eso nos vamos a asegurar de que
realmente sabemos lo que sabemos va
bueno pero voy a continuar entonces si
tomara por aquí otro punto otro punto y
le pongo x x también sería un radio
entonces lo voy a poner a x así con
barra para referirme al segmento también
también
es un radio
un radio radio
muy bien bueno pero hay otro tipo de
líneas y de segmentos que pueden
interactuar con un círculo por ejemplo
si tomo un punto aquí en la orilla del
círculo déjame llamarla déjame llamarle
a ese punto el punto d entonces puedo
pensar en una recta que toque al círculo
únicamente en el punto de una recta más
o menos de este estilo a algo así sale
si tenemos una recta así que toca a un
círculo únicamente en un punto se le
conoce como una tangente me voy a poner
aquí tangente
y nos podemos referir a ella de varias
formas si conociéramos otro punto por
ejemplo si supiéramos que este punto de
acá se llama el punto b entonces
podríamos referirnos a esta línea como
la línea de poniéndole arriba que es una
línea así con doble flecha pero también
simplemente podríamos ponerle aquí una l
una l
y entonces podríamos referirnos a esta
línea como la línea l bueno y si tenemos
que la línea del justo toca en un punto
decimos que pues lo voy a escribir por
acá la línea la línea
línea l estany gente es tangente
gente y lo voy a poner así al círculo
con centro en a es importante indicar
que el centro es a porque a lo mejor
podemos tener por acá otro círculo que
tenga centro m y nos queremos referir a
que el eees tangente a éste de acá y no
a este de acá va bueno entonces
escribiríamos así la línea l estany
gente al círculo a va ahora podríamos
tener otra recta que no corta en un
punto sino en dos por ejemplo podríamos
tener algo de este estilo imaginemos que
tenemos una recta que se ve así y que
los puntos donde corta al círculo a la
orilla del círculo son este de acá y
este de acá que les vamos a llamar
efe efe ig
si tenemos algo de este estilo una línea
que corta en dos puntos entonces decimos
que es una secante lo voy a escribir por
acá le voy a poner
fg fg así
con su doble flechita para indicar que
es una línea es una secante
se cante se cante que cante muy bien
entonces una secante es una línea que
toca el círculo en dos puntos pero
podría interesarnos también fijarnos en
este segmento o sea no en toda toda la
línea sino únicamente en el segmento que
va de efe ag déjame pintar este segmento
del color morado
en color morado este de acá
y si tenemos un segmento de este estilo
que une dos puntos en la orilla del
círculo entonces a ese segmento le
llamamos una cuerda del círculo para lo
voy a poner por acá
fg fg pero ahora como segmento
únicamente como segmento es una cuerda
una cuerda
de de el círculo vale del círculo con
centro en a recuerda que está indica que
es el centro eso no quiere decir que a
éste en la orilla sino que los puntos
son equidistantes
a queda justo a la mitad va ahora hay un
tipo especial de cuerdas que son
aquellas cuerdas que pasan justo por el
centro del círculo y a una cuerda que
sea así le llamamos un diámetro déjame
dibujar una de esas la voy a poner en
color naranja y sería más o menos algo
así empieza en una orilla del círculo
pasa por el centro y llega a la otra
orilla a la otra orilla va a llegar al
punto exactamente opuesto imaginemos que
este punto de acá se llama h bueno vamos
a llamarlo h y entonces decimos que f h
efe h el segmento f h es un es una
cuerda por supuesto pero como es una
cuerda que pasa por el centro decimos
que es
un diámetro
guiada metro
de de la circunferencia
muy bien una observación importante es
que un diámetro justo está formado por
dos radios aquí tenemos un radio y aquí
tenemos otro lo podemos escribir en
términos de longitudes como f h
efe h es igual a f
efe +
h recuerda que si no le pongo barritas
son longitudes entonces esto también lo
puedo poner como dos veces a h la
longitud de un diámetro es exactamente
dos veces la longitud de un radio muy
bien entonces ya tenemos cómo
interactúan algunas rectas y segmentos
con la circunferencia déjame pasar a
otra cosa que son los arcos para eso voy
a tener que dibujar un nuevo círculo
porque si no el otro dibujo va a quedar
muy encimado entonces aquí voy a poner
este círculo por aquí voy a poner su
centro que digamos se llama b creo que
tiene que ir un poco más arriba más o
menos ahí entonces se llama digamos b y
voy a poner algunos puntos alrededor
voy a poner aquí
puntos 2 3 4 5 y pensemos que esos
puntos se llaman pues se podrían llamar
como sea pero déjame ponerle j k ese
tipo
muy bien ahora lo que nos va a interesar
o la pregunta que nos vamos a hacer es
como se llama la longitud que recorremos
sobre la orilla de un punto de estos a
otro por ejemplo déjame tomar el color
rojo e indicar esta orilla de acá la que
va de jota acá
sobre sobre el borde del círculo como le
llamamos a esta longitud bueno pues a
esta longitud le llamamos un arco más
bien a este a este segmento curvo le
llamamos arco y ese arco tiene una
longitud entonces en lo que nos estamos
fijando es es como en esta curva en esta
curva que va de jota acá sobre la orilla
y eso es a lo que se conoce como arco
para denotar un arco escribimos sus dos
extremos j
ica y arriba ponemos una pequeña curva
así ahora te debes de estar preguntando
algo cómo podemos distinguir entre el
arco jk que va de aquí para acá y el
arco jk que va por el otro lado bueno
pues a este arco que es el arco de menor
longitud le llamamos el arco menor el
arco menor
jk y lo denotamos así si quisiéramos
irnos por el otro lado déjame tomarlo
déjame tomar el color verde y
y dibujar por acá si quisiéramos irnos
por este lado por donde mide más
entonces a eso le llamaríamos el arco
mayor y para denotar lo usualmente se
indica otro de los puntos que estén
sobre ese arco por ejemplo a este arco
que puse en verde le podemos llamar el
arco jota jota
j y k esa es una forma de referirnos a
él pero como también t y s están ahí
podríamos ponerle el arco jota teca o
bien el arco j s acá por supuesto con su
línea curva arriba eso que es un poco
feo algo así y algo así estas tres cosas
son exactamente lo mismo son tres formas
de decir exactamente lo mismo de
referirnos al arco mayor que va de jota
acá bueno pero lo importante es que si
tenemos dos puntos hay dos arcos a un
arco de este estilo le llamamos arco
menor
arco menor
que es el de menor longitud y aún acosa
a un objeto de este estilo que va por el
otro lado le llamamos el arco arco mayor
mayor le voy a dejar hasta aquí con las
definiciones
nos vemos en próximos vídeos para
empezar a utilizarlas en algunos otros
contextos